three my life come on an immigrant the
two-time governor of California 72 years
old
it's like Trump almost right yeah dude
how about he [ __ ] his warlock of a
cleaner and got her pregnant and it's
like yeah cool man I'm not gonna had a
kid I'm not gonna comment on I think she
was probably pretty sexy he's got his
son first sunny day is a happy kid
son son got his genetics yeah Alan have
you seen her Brian what when she was
younger when they [ __ ] dude when she was
young probably Barlow well now she's an
old daddy when she was cleaning the
house that's not true that's Jo lady no
she's no lady now and she was younger
that's her little younger shut your
[ __ ] mouth to me what I'm saying is
how cool is that that he did that and
just oh we did a baller move he's such a
[ __ ] maniac and me he's such a guided
guy he bright just got a shower but you
know she was there fluffing the pillows
and he's all all right it's go time
Yeah right yeah well there there there
that's better than when she's younger
let go there when she's you know yeah
right there all right you know the thing
is you you can't you ask you don't
become the governor in the seventh I'm
not having appetite and you don't become
the Terminator by not wanting to [ __ ]
anything that moves okay you got an
appetite that pictures amazing right
there this guy is this guy he's just got
golf here's what's what a handsome son
of a [ __ ] here's what's crazy about
horse neighing his other kids
good-looking kid they'll have his
genetics muscular the max and kid does
he looks just like he's the own that got
his actual physical man yeah
good-looking kid yeah and he's kind of
into bodybuilding
yeah yes other kids are into like acting
and their feelings and [ __ ] just kids
Jack listen he's he's God look at kid
though the kids don't look like that
hey he's Mexican dude do you know the
type of [ __ ] that what that kid's gonna
do with his
work ethic and those genetic you can
take over the [ __ ] world god bless
him look at them it's a beautiful boys
listen man all because she was fluffy
god bless his mother god bless his
mother his mother was like you know look
he's an attractive dude who knows what
the situation was that whole thing's
crazy tiptoe around no I don't we don't
situation feel uncomfy what's been made
I feel uncomfortable because like you
just can't do that right but what a
beautiful result what a beautiful result
what a beautiful mistake but you can't
beautiful can't have sex with the maid
why not
it's in your house man why not well
source failure why not are you there's
just some rules who knows what they who
maybe they're separated I forgive all
parties I forgive all parties it's all
good it's all good but he's you know he
died he owned it you know you got the
family together as I care you know is
Morelle de who's here every Wednesday
she's pregnant they're like please
that's a true yeah
is that true yeah you owned it just Oh
told him he did hmm but I don't think
maria shriver knew until it all came out
did she nope he told the family that's
why they're closed now they're all like
still they still like hanging out he did
what he wanted when he had sex with
everybody because they all wanted to
click on that one when she's walking on
the beach which says housekeeper claims
he's a guy who walks in more of a wife
than Schwarzenegger is oh then Maria
later I mean you know what you know what
here's the thing he fathered that child
well he loves that boy we don't know
that well it looks like they hang out it
looks like they don't want to think
they're gonna go follow they they look
he loves his son dude they are like it
yeah that kid is a spitting image as
long as you know a boy loves this a
father loves his kids I'm good if you
have if you want to have 14 kids love
them all and treat them well okay as
long as you do that if you don't
I got no time for you bottom line sir
interesting yes sometimes just gotta
that kid's jacked it looks just like his
pop very hot the same hair to wear this
home I'm proud of dude Lisa's genetics
get you know those monster genetics or
someone yeah man they live on in the
young boy God he looks like Danny pulled
impressed she went on it was young
you ever seen aura at 16 let's not get
crazy now you seen all that signagi 16
but I have one he was younger you know
no 16 years old there's a picture of him
in it's mind-blowing
he's ah yeah dude yeah he was look at
that there is 16 year old jack that's
good that's some good genetics big
Austrians a big Austrian man grew up on
milk that making kid got it man I mean
I'm gonna come to the United States as
an Austrian and and become the biggest
bodybuilding world the biggest movie
star in the world and the governor twice
over dude no with you in a better story
what the maze I'm gonna come to America
get pregnant by the governor and the
biggest movie star of all time third I
have to say I got you think about it bro
vibe that's a it's a coup it's what we
call a coup and it worked out that is
pretty amazing pretty amazing why
wouldn't you you got a little Arnold in
you and now stop dreaming
what you got a little Arnold in you it's
tough for guys like let's say let's say
my god let's say my goal is to get Kim
Kardashian pregnant it's gonna be a
tough run for your boy how do I get in
there I can't clean a house no I keep
their nose can I hire me as you could be
the pool boy no no you hire my big ass
is the pool boy how can I get in the
house to be around my my feeling and how
am I gonna get in a room here's what I
saw the shower and I dicker down here's
what I think if you're there as the
personal trainer dude
oh man tell how we're gonna do oh you're
right on time
this is a great idea time go you come in
there with your cauliflower ears your
big old long hair now yeah and you got
to do that you got to come at me John
Stamos I'm at me John Stamos and by the
way you're just there to spot you do
their spot let's do some squats yeah I'm
gonna make sure you're hit build it
bring it bring your hips in a little bit
is brilliant yes in a little bit there
you go and now you're just talking this
way that's it there you go now breathe
breathe breathe I got you I got you
don't worry I know it's a lot of weight
I got you I got you I got you there you
go all the way down can you go a little
further there you go I think I'm gonna
okay they say no I'm dumping her in the
pool house don't be froze
don't say dumping it's Kim Kardashian
have a little respect or Kylie either or
listen I make a call I within than the
made I made called you break you at the
end of the day you're gonna break you're
gonna break them all down
Chloe seems like a tough case to crack
but I'm not a tough case you see they
seems like a tough case she might be the
first to go at the end of the day all
the Kardashians have a little shop in
them but yeah and they all have your kid
I'm not black tough they only like black
boy you're almost black dude you're
Samoan black Mexican you you be a lot of
things yeah I get a hybrid gotchas a
baddie like black women love you there
they're all like here so it doesn't
because you're you're you're at your
ethnically ambiguous dude that racially
ambiguous dude that is the move though I
go in as was that trainer that Oh Kylie
she's something else that doctor no that
one's Kim Kim yeah mmm yeah that doctor
can mine mine that presenting I thought
that Brazilian butt thing that they do
is incredible they take the fat and just
displace it now you know the new thing
they do they take fat people who can go
donate their fat like a sperm bank and
they take that fact I don't think so
it's hard you're out of a job they do
it's a new thing and it's a power form
they turn in a powder form how I know
all this I have no idea this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]